situé en marge du pays à l'écart des
axes vitaux vivotant au rythme lent des
horloges du
passé discrète au point de se faire
oublier a été considérée pendant
longtemps comme une petite cité
provinciale engourdie dans ses murailles
plus riche de passer que
d'avenir depuis 20 ans change le
festival de musique en est un exemple
les vieilles et vénérables pierres
abrite maintenant de prestigieux
concerts
le théâtre œuvre de l'architecte
visionnaire Claude Nicolas ledou
accueille concert récital et la finale
du concours des jeunes chefs
[Musique]
d'orchestre le palais de justice ancien
Parlement de élégante construction du
16e siècle où sont donnés les concerts
de musique de chambre et de musique
contemporaine